bonsoir je vais vous raconter le début
d'une belle histoire
6 août 2014 bon ça démarre mal des shs
envahi la plaine de ninive en irak et la
ville de qaraqosh berceau du
christianisme chrétiens et minorités
religieuses
puis vers erbil au kurdistan irakien où
ils sont protégés par les pechmergas il
fuit la nuit en emportant leurs biens
les plus précieux par 45 degrés le jour
dans les embouteillages parce qu'il ya
qu une route qui mène vers erbil ils
sont 120 mid season 2014
notre petite famille mon mari olivier ma
fille lise âgé de 7 ans et moi même nous
préparons nos bagages pour partir en
vacances
un drame de plus aux informations alors
là un drame de trop peut-être
nous sommes les spectateurs otages deux
réalisateurs barbare d'un mauvais film
on les entend presque rire en sourdine
de notre impuissance et ce jour là la
colère nantes et mon mari et moi nous
décidons d'agir et de nous proposer
comme famille d'accueil pour accueillir
chez nous une deux trois personnes
maximum
on a un petit peu d espace alors qu on
contacte le soir même en deux heures de
temps une association dont on trouve les
coordonnées sur internet et on se
déclare famille d'accueil
quinze jours après l association nous
rappelle en disant ben voilà on a un
couple avec un petit garçon est ce que
vous êtes toujours d'accord nous on vous
met en contact avec eux mais alors après
on vous laisse vous débrouiller
vous avez un réseau non nous n'ont pas
de réseau particulier on a quelques amis
mais c'est pas vraiment un réseau et est
ce que vous êtes toujours d'accord
dit oui on est toujours d'accord on part
en vacances et en septembre
là on retombe sur terre et on se dit qu
est-ce qu on est partis peur de
l'inconnu peur de l'étranger sous notre
toit
quels risques ont fait courir à notre
petite fille de sept ans est-ce qu'on
est irresponsable donc angoisse 6
novembre 2014 balle et voilà il arrive à
l'aéroport
donc on est allé les chercher on a fait
une grande affiche pour dire bienvenue
en arabe parce qu'on parle pas l'arabe
on parle encore moins l'araméen et eux
ne parlent ni français ni anglais
donc voilà notre famille réunie nos deux
familles réunies que je vais vous
présenter sur la gauche à la le papa à
sa gauche son épouse int leur petit
garçon raïs âgé de 6 ans mon mari
olivier mas phillies âgé de 7 ans à
l'époque et moi-même premier repas pris
ensemble donc pas un mot en commun on
qu'on échange par le langage des signes
en décrivant les objets sur la table en
les traduisant ou en français ou en
arabe ou en araméen on sait même pas et
puis très vite la vie s'organise
notre petit reiss est scolarisé dans
l'école de lise
juste en grande section de maternelle et
les parents hinte à la sont inscrits à
des cours de français auprès
d'associations locales aux associations
lilloises organismes des lois et des
bénévoles viennent à la maison pour les
aider à reprendre les cours et a récité
alors int est une véritable fée du logis
c'est une parfaite maîtresse de maison
qui cuisinent délicieusement bien et je
suis même un peu gêné vis à vis de mon
voisinage en me demandant mais que vont
penser nos voisins s qui s'imaginent
qu'on les a fait venir pour travailler
donc angoisse
donc voilà mais on a beaucoup profité on
a très bien mangé et alla de son côté à
tourner un petit peu en rond c'est
difficile pour lui
de ne rien faire et tous les matins il
est chaud c'est habillée prêt à partir
travailler mon mari à 6h30 mais mon mari
peut pas l'emmener bien sûr et donc il
reste à la maison alors en trois
semaines on a réussi à se parler par des
mots simples assez rapidement et reis
lui a parlé beaucoup plus rapidement
c'est impressionnant est le premier mot
qu'a dit rice à sa défaite au bout de
quatre jours son premier mot en français
ces cinq minutes parce qu'il écoute
élise et il s'est rendu compte que cinq
minutes c'était un mot magique pour pas
aller se coucher pour pas prendre sa
douche pour pas manger donc ça a été son
premier mot en français c'est véridique
aussi en trois semaines passent et
l'apparition des anges gardiens on n'a
rien demandé on n'a pas de réseau on
s'est dit on se débrouille et les gens
sont venus se présenter et dire bah moi
je peux aider je peux faire c'est aussi
je peux faire cela
le voisinage les paroissiens pascaline t
on les accompagne et vont beaucoup
beaucoup à la messe est il raciste et le
notre père en araméen le langage du
christ donc c'est impressionnant à
écouter donc le les gens se sont
mobilisés autour de nous et
et donc très rapidement on a senti que
on n'avait presque plus besoin de rien
faire en quelques temps les le voisinage
a apporté ce cette petite famille vers
vers l'aide à l'autonomie enfin verveine
l'aide à l'insertion tout au moins 1er
février 2015 à la entre en cdd au garage
gambetta seco comme carrossier et très
rapidement il fait des miracles et ils
passent en cdi dont classé à la porte
vers l'autonomie int est enceinte de son
deuxième enfant et ont fait une demande
de logement social du monde qui aboutira
en septembre 2015
le 15 septembre et s'installeront à
haubourdin et lui jours après naîtra
christian dont qui porte le nom du papa
d'olivier qui est décédé dans ce qui
renforce nos liens familiaux et les
parents les parrains et marraines de
christian sont mon papa et la maman
d'olivier mans marie lise et rei se sont
baptisés tom et jerry donc ils se
disputent comme frères et soeurs et sont
devenus de très bons amis bien sûr donc
au fil de ces mois passés ensemble on
pense qu'on a été les premiers
consommateurs de champagne de france on
a bu à toutes les occasions il ya eu le
cdi
le logement social l'appartement enfin
l'appartement oui bien sûr la carte de
séjour
toute occasion a été bonne à prendre
donc on a vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
profiter de tout ça et puis hein on a
été on a été extrêmement marqué quand
ils nous ont quitté pour s'installer
chez eux et on s'est rendu compte qu'on
avait tissé des liens familiaux
réellement familiaux cédant elle est
aujourd'hui une famille de 6 et on sait
par le biais d'autres personnes qui ont
accueilli comme nous que c'est la même
relation fusionnelle en fait qui
s'instaure est aujourd'hui bien sûr on
se voit très très très souvent au
minimum trois fois par semaine à peu
près ce qui se passe aussi c'est que
grâce à eux alors nous on leur a donné
de la tension on leur a donné du temps
mais eux nous ont apporté beaucoup
beaucoup de paix et tout autour on a
découvert un océan de bienveillance des
gens qui nous ont entourés qui se sont
manifestés et là on voit ici en photo
nos amis qui sont de nouveaux amis on
les connaissait pas ya six mois et donc
tous ces gens là ont vraiment porté à la
interest va jusqu'à leur autonomie donc
on pense qu'on a en soi le vouloir semer
une graine café des racines et
visiblement il ya quelque chose d'assez
vigoureux qui pousse parce qu en octobre
à trois familles de notre région des web
qui nous ont dit va nous on veut faire
comme vous on voudrait accueillir alors
on s'est dit il faut quand même qu'on
crée quelque chose une association pour
les aider parce que nous on a un
historique
on sait on a des petites astuces donc on
a fondé une association avec 12
fondateur qui s'appelle agir en web qui
veut dire accueillir guider et insérer
les réfugiés voilà les deux fondateurs
donc l'objectif c'est de guider jusqu'à
l'autonomie
les réfugiés ont les lâchera pas tant
qu'ils seront pas autonome avec un
contrat de travail en moins pour un des
membres de la famille
deuxième point important c'est on tient
à ce que souhaite deux familles qu'ils
soient unis une famille accueillante une
famille accueillie au sein d'un réseau
parce que le réseau va leur donner
confiance dans l'avenir va les porter
troisième point c'est le respect de
l'identité de l'étranger donc
aujourd'hui on essaye d'accueillir des
gens qui ont vécu la même histoire
oh que ces étrangers qui arrivent ici
qui ont tous laissé la veille centre
avec trois valises qui ont tous laissé
là bas et qui ont leurs familles
éparpillées ou encore en irak ou aux
états unis ou en allemagne ou en
australie puisse encore quand même
communiquer sur leur histoire et sur
leur culture avec des gens ayant vécu la
même chose
notre association le premier but c'est
d'abord la formation au français
l'alphabétisation donc et puis l'aide à
l'insertion par le soutien scolaire et
la recherche d'emploi et puis bien sûr
également tout l'administratif pour tout
ce qui est papier le suivi santé alors à
l'heure où je vous parle aujourd'hui 11
juin 2016
la famille caac ici au milieu est en
train d'arriver
auquel cas la famille d'accueil est
partie les chercher à l'aéroport ils
s'entraident à 14h30
donc c'est la huitième familles qui
arrivent dans les weppes qui sont
accueillis
fois en anglais et à la fin de l'année
ce seront douze familles qui seront
accueillis chennouf enfin dans notre
région d'iwate
donc on pense que cette graine qui a été
semé son qu'on le veuille réellement
elle a besoin de produire une petite
forêt et aujourd'hui c'est tout c'est
tous ces gens qui portent comme ça vers
l'insertion des réfugiés vivent ensemble
des moments de partage et de joie de
vivre ensemble extraordinaire
aujourd'hui quand je regarde les
informations avec mon mari on est
toujours choqué parce qu'on peut y voir
mais quand on est en poste en la foi en
l'homme et on est heureux de d'essayer
de construire un monde qui nous convient
alors je souhaite dire merci à allah
interest qui sont ici ma famille shaw
crâne josé l'homme comme on dit en arabe
pour tous qui nous apporte
bonsoir à tous je suis très contente
d'être en france parce que nous sommes
en sécurité
nous avons beaucoup d'amis français et
des grandes familles catherine olivier
ellis ils sont comme ma famille
catherine elle est comme ma soeur olivia
gay comme mon frère
ellis est comme des enfants et une fois
j'ai entendu disent qu'ils demandent
dares
reus l'iris qui demande à l'iss lee est
ce que tu aimes bien avoir un petit
frère et déguisements j'en ai deux
questions et maintenant je suis dans
l'association des girouettes jet pour
faire la traduction entre les familles
d'accueil et le refuge et merci
bonsoir je suis très content de rippert
france ou non nous sommes contents de
leur arrivée en france tu me suis fait
beaucoup d'amis français
je suis trouvé de travail
je suis content on en france parce que
la france est la main de deuxième pays
merci
quand didier pas là je suis triste
moi c'est pareil comme s il est pas là
je suis triste avec mes copines on fait
un groupe pour essayer d'aider les
personnes mais comment sera plus grande
on vous référez une association et ont
fait ça parce qu'on sait qu'il faut
beaucoup d'associations d'un monde pour
aider les personnes
merci